So let's see what happens if we substitute zero for near
in the equation. Here's the substitution. Let's simplify. This element goes to
negative one and this element goes to zero. If you look at
this matrix and examine its effect on the various coordinates, you'll notice
he following: first, the last collumn was all zeros, so the
W value of the coordinate will have no effect on the result.
This leaves only the incoming Z value of the coordinate affecting the
output Z and W value. Whatever the Z value is coming in,
the resulting Z and W will be that original
Z value multiplied by negative 1. In other words,
the output Z and W values will always be
identical. When you divide by W, the result will always
be 1, except for the case where W is
0. The distance of an object from the camera
will almost always be 1, which is not a
useful result if you're trying to use the Z buffer.